and we are learning more details tonight
about the man that nasp says allegedly
caused a fatal crash in pahrump over the
weekend three people died including two
children in that crash on u.s 95.
christian gassades joining us now in
studio with what nevada state police
were saying about the cause christian
well denise tonight county sheriff has
identified the three victims as
41-year-old thomas katan twelve-year-old
abiel katan and seven-year-old ayanna
katan nsp tells us the driver was behind
the wheel of a silver volvo that that
person was crystal's verocnos he was
arrested for a dui and faces several
charges for causing a fatal chain
reaction crash
tonight christos verochnose is at nye
county detention center after he was
arrested at the scene of this fatal
accident nevada state police say this
collision on u.s 95 at mile marker 27
near amargosa valley happened around 11
30 sunday morning preliminary details
show rocknows was driving northbound in
this silver volvo and failed to stay
within his travel lane as he crossed
into oncoming traffic the volvo
sideswiped a truck towing a camper and
hit a gmc yukon it smashed into a gray
chrysler minivan where three of the five
passengers inside were killed according
to nsp including two juveniles a dog
traveling with rocknose was also killed
this crash did have u.s 95 between state
route 160 and 373 closed for hours
while ferracnos is currently at the nye
county detention center he faces 11
charges including three counts of dui
causing death and resisting a public
officer christian cassette is live local
now